au coeur du village d'une menou okyo et
benjamin rejoint une maison de la
famille carrasco qui était aussi
l'ancien atelier de l'artiste
quelque chose me dit que c'est la maison
là bas je sais pas pourquoi je ne sais
pas pressentiment je pense que
maintenant j'en suis sûr à 100%
regardez moi ça c'est ça c'est pas une
maison d'artiste c'est de la clôture
c'est coloré en tout cas du jardin
jusque dans la rue sculptures et
création entoure la maison
difficile de passer à côté de cette
maison dans le village imagine bien je
vais te montrer d'autres font d'autres
encore
ah ça y est on y est oui
au cours de sa vie l'artiste a réalisé
plusieurs centaines de sculptures
alors tu peut remarquer que dans la
sculpture et travaille beaucoup la
courbe est la première chose que je
remarque déjà c'est qu'il ya une vraie
variété de types de pierres en fait car
à ce qu il disait qu'il était un
habitant du monde et donc cette quête de
mondialité va la chercher dans les
pierres donc là par exemple on est sur
un marbre de vérone ça c'est un onyx
d'argentine les pièces noires c'est un
marin brawn war de belgique
il avait une connaissance de la pierre
qui était très étonnante parce qu'il
disait une pierre sa part pour carrasco
les bières étaient des éléments vivants
bien que son coeur ni poumon et cerveau
pour lui elle dégageait une énergie
sensuelle érotique
[Musique]
alors oui bien sûr au contraire carrasco
commis chercher l'érotisme car regarde
ce qu'il ya derrière toi c'est pareil tu
peux les caresser tu vas sentir au
niveau des doigts que quand tu caresse
par exemple la barre double et un marbre
comme celui-ci du portugal la sensation
tactile n'est pas la même pour lui ne
pas avoir envie de toucher ces pierres
c'est qu'il avait raté sa mission
puisqu'il cherche au côté sensuel de
chacun des matériaux ok donc si je
résume en fait vu le nombre de
disciplines qu'il a pu tester le nombre
de pierres sur lesquels il a pu
travailler
c'était vraiment un touche à tout bah
oui mais parce que carrasco et l'estimé
que quand on est en vie il faut il faut
expérimenter son saladier triste hélas
pas dû s'ennuyer
jamais
profitez de la vie dans la famille
carrasco c'est une valeur qui compte
aujourd'hui
petits et grands se sont rassemblés pour
fabriquer des saletés niasse une
spécialité bolivienne j'aime ce genre de
surprise pas de la nourriture tu peux te
dire que tu vas me faire plaisir
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans une salle teigne
alors y'a des légumes il ya de la viande
dérives des raisins secs des oeufs
à les écouter ça je pense que j'aurais
du mal à en manger toute seule
[Musique]
on va vous voyez pas besoin d'aller très
loin pour mettre un petit prix en
bolivie
moi je m'en prends une dernière pour la
route et je vous dis à bientôt